joining me now is Congressman Jim Jordan
ranking member of the House Judiciary
Committee Molly Hemingway
editor-in-chief of the Federalists and
Fox News contributor and Monica Crowley
former assistant Secretary of the
Treasury and host of The Monaco Crowley
podcast thank you all for being here
Congressman I'll start with you the
president said Maga forces are
determined to take this country
backwards how should Republicans respond
and has the soul of the nation now been
saved that the speech is over
now I actually think Raymond he came
across as a sad angry kind of bitter old
man here kind of looked like the
lighting and all sort of like Darth
Vader it seemed to me and understand in
the past four days he has called half
the country fascist and extremists and
the country really wants the real
problems out there they want them to
dress like like you pointed out in your
statement in your in your monologue we
went from a secure border to no border
we went from Safe Streets to record
crime we went from stable prices to a
41-year high inflation rate and we went
from two dollar gas to five dollar gas
all in 18 months I think the nation
would kind of like those addressed
versus being called extremists and
fascist and have the government now
Target your freedoms and Liberties like
we have seen from the Biden
Administration justice department now
Monica you worked in the Trump white
house so you know Optics if you were
going to liken your political opponents
to Nazis maybe employing a backdrop that
looks like it could have come out of
1940s Germany and then this opening was
not the way to go
my fellow Americans
please if you have a seat
tell you
I speak to you tonight from sacred
ground in America
uh Monica
can you remember an example of a prime
time address by a president so laced
with ugly and divisive political
rhetoric and a backdrop that looked like
that well first of all
injury there was almost satanic with
that blood red lighting and the two
marines behind him it was just insane
look this was a garbage speech by a
garbage president and the fact he gave
this disgusting dangerous speech at
Independence Hall is a sacrilege he
deliberately used two phrases he talked
about extremism because of the
association with terrorists and
terrorism and he also spoke about Maga
forces as of 75 million Americans are
part of some subterfuge gorilla group
but he deliberately used that kind of
language because he is making no secret
of his intention of turning half the
country into enemies of the state and
the purpose of that is so that they can
Leverage The Power of the State against
us this is an incredibly dangerous
moment for the country every dictator
throughout history has employed this
kind of language with that kind of
backdrop and for most Americans I think
they're they're really starting to see
what is actually happening here which is
that the most dangerous threat we face
is that our own government has now been
fully weaponized against us to the point
where not only are the most fearsome
agencies of the of the country uh turned
against us from the doj FBI and IRS but
also the president of the United States
who is supposed to effectively represent
us all and instead has turned to all of
his forces and fire upon half the
country Molly then Biden went on to
claim that it is the right who is
engaged in grievance and culture wars
watch
we're going to make the 21st century
another American Century because the
world needs us to
[Applause]
that's where we need to focus our energy
not in the past not on divisive culture
wars
not on the politics of grievance
but on the future we can build together
Molly who started these culture wars
over school curricula and and uh
abortion and how is returning abortion
to the states destroying democracy you
know I keep thinking you're making all
these allusions to the summer of
violence that we saw in 2020 where
cities were destroyed with arson where
dozens of people were killed where
thousands of cops were injured where so
much destruction happened and president
Trump gave a speech at Mount Rushmore
where he did condemn political violence
and also praised our country and spoke
about the higher good that we all should
aspire to and the corporate media called
that speech dark and divisive this
speech is easily the most disgraceful
speech from a president in recent
decades it is horrifying how he is
issuing a call to war against every
single American who didn't vote for him
or doesn't support him and that's a lot
of people because his approval ratings
are horrible and part of the reason why
is because as you note Democrat policies
are very corrosive to the body politic
the culture War where they are attacking
people for recognizing biological
reality or for lying about what the
Dobbs decision does which enables people
to have a say in whether to protect
women and children from from what we've
experienced under the abortion regime
previously this is just it's a really
dark and dangerous time and it's at a
time when violence has been committed
recently against churches Republican
offices maternal Care Centers Supreme
Court Justices who've been nearly
assassinated he didn't condemn any of
that and it's very dangerous yeah no The
Selective outrage Congressman Jordan
here's what Biden thinks about 74
million Americans listen I want your
reaction
Maggie Republicans do not respect the
Constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they did not recognize the will of the
people
they refuse to accept the results of a
free election
now now Congressman he he constantly
tried to invoke president Trump and mega
Republicans but whether president Trump
is in the picture or not one gets the
feeling they would be branded in the
same way with the same language
right no and Monica Molly are both right
they are trying to weaponize the
government against half the population
against any Republican any conservative
anyone who voted for President Trump and
we see that it's so bad that we have had
14 I've talked about this 14
whistleblowers come to our office as FBI
agents come to us as whistleblowers
talking about this whole narrative to
treat everyone and label everyone as an
extremist who simply opposes the radical
policies of the left and of the Democrat
Party as Molly said this is a dangerous
and frightening time the country though
sees it I've been out across the country
helping candidates the people I talk to
they see it for what it is they're very
nervous and I think they're going to
show up in a big way on November 8th and
say enough of this we've got to put this
in check and put Republicans back in
control Monica a new Quinnipiac poll
shows that a majority of Democrats and
Republicans both agree the nation's
democracy is in danger of collapse 67
percent of Americans agree with that 69
percent of both Republicans and
Democrats also agree yeah Monica isn't
that actually proof that Biden is
dividing the country because obviously
that they think democracy is falling for
different reasons Republicans and
Democrats and it's not about Unity
yeah exactly right when you see the
split along those lines and you see the
the numbers almost identical for
republicans and Democrats and even
Independents it tells you that they're
viewing the divisions in the country as
extremely problematic for the future of
America but for very different reasons
this speech tonight was like an orgy of
projection everything that President
Biden accused Donald Trump and
conservatives and the American first
movement of they themselves are guilty
of every single thing that he accused
our side of doing he and the Democrats
are guilty of and I think most Americans
now see that and and I do think this is
a precarious moment because we're at a
real Tipping Point here and I think a
lot of the people he accused of being
enemies of the state today really feel
like this is the hill to die on you know
the other side is at war with the
Constitution free market economics
economic freedom individual liberty and
we're out here trying to preserve all of
of those things for the children and and
grandchildren of this country and the
other side is literally at War the
Republican who is running for office
needs to understand that and campaign on
that for the future Molly I want to get
to you before I run out of time I want
to get your reaction to the media's
response to this speech listen
there were those moments of the American
dream right where he reminded the
country of what does actually make
America great and what we can do from
here right there was Hope just as as
Lincoln gave the house divided speech
here is a time when President Biden has
chosen
Molly your take on this apparently a
group of historians met with Biden and
convinced him that he was like FDR and
Lincoln FDR before the war in Lincoln
during the war your take on this trying
to cast Biden as a wartime president I
think it's very difficult to defend
anything in this speech and anyone who
does it is having to work really hard to
do it you do not unite the country by
going to war against half the country
you don't unite the country by
weaponizing the Department of Justice to
take out any and all political opponents
I mean it is just sheer gaslighting what
we're going through with the amount of
executive Authority that is being held
by by Joe Biden and how he's abusing
that whether it's through the the loan
scheme that he's using to buy votes his
weaponization of the Department of
Justice or any of the other policy
issues that he's going through and it's
to to it's just it's it's
you wonder you wonder how much more can
happen and that corporate media will
defend but apparently we see tonight
that they're willing to defend and
excuse anything Molly I sympathize with
you I think everybody's at a loss for
words how do you even put this fiction
in in context because it's so at odds
with the reality before us panel I thank
you all for being here tonight on this
important night hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else